[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that's called the I'm sitting perfectly
straight do I look like I'm moving
half-asian Lord no no lawyer bill
Richman is here today and he's very
serious I am he is very sick as a
freshman I know what will make me happy
was if you do the hawk neck challenge oh
is that where you can move your body but
not your head yeah yeah you're failing
total epic and you do it no do it if my
head fills the entire screen was a
different bird that does this all birds
do it I think a fowl why even even
turtle does something to do with flight
but I understand like why do they decide
in other words you could just start them
anywhere in space but they decide that
oh this is how my head is supposed to be
like why couldn't your head be down
there I just readjust they want it to be
even theirs make any sense it can
recalibrate so when they're flying they
can do this and turn without have a
steven crowder destroys birds and fly
directly into the other Cardinal that
they see in the window hashtag Gambians
- there's a there's a cardinal right
outside of my window it's out of my
garage and every time we're in there
doing jiu-jitsu he just boom hits the
garage window he wants to learn and then
when I pulled a car in Bora Bora and
then I found out today he was actually
dive-bombing into my neighbor's car Wow
I don't know and like the thing is I
kind of like him I'm gonna miss him when
he's gone you know he's a he's a
vivacious little prayer got it red -
communist alright so we are going to
have an ash once a are you yeah
absolutely
sounds like a horrible idea are we
kidding I came into the show and he
brought in one of those energy drinks I
think oh man I'm really dragging yeah
and I have a sip he's like yeah you can
have and then it was one fluid motion he
was yeah you can have don't drink it not
good you don't look sick that's because
I Everage Lee look sick no you look good
you look like you have some color oh
thank you yellow thank you well yeah
it's tough it's not now just a tinge of
Rose okay so we'll get to an ash
wednesday but before that we're going to
be talking about the black sit so
question of the day have you heard of
this supposed black sit that's occurring
with black Americans they're leaving the
United States moving back to Africa it's
being advocated by a lot of black
activists do you know anyone personally
do you think blacks need to leave
because not me this is what they are
advocating over at Essence magazine I
think we have to get we have this
article right here from essence there's
this increasingly sort of common claim
that black Americans can we say blacks
do what do we is this blacks okay I feel
like that's wrong and that's percent of
Americans but African a lot of them are
in African American they don't like it
some of you read me the riot act when I
said African American blacks coloreds
to get away from racism this is what
they wrote about in essence magazine
even saying that this is a viable
solution right now it's being suggested
by black activists under the rule of
Trump so just give you a feel by the way
for the author of this article has kind
of gone viral and it's been echoed by
places I think like the New York Times
and maybe was Huffington Post's Kristen
Kirsten Kristin Kirsten got a think
about that savaii I want to make sure I
get her name right she claims it in
America black Americans will go with
that that sort of feathers it up black
in there yeah took half from African
American half from blacks black
Americans that they're supposedly living
in occupied territory and that the
police are given them specifically under
Trump the right to kill them with
impunity that's part of the premise
let's hear from her we talked about
what's happened since Ferguson you know
what's happened since then patrols
I played black people back to plantation
when the crime was not the the
humanizing institutional violence of
slavery it was Ashley people seeking
freedom and they were meant to bring
them back so again we're talking about
occupied territories we're talking about
oppressed communities we're talking
about militarized police departments who
have been given so right the kill with
impunity and it happens over and over
and over again does your character have
a hair net no wait we all played guess
who right yeah okay I really should get
an actually in the prompter and then a
ferret apparently start using it oh look
what happened here this whole thing just
shut down thank you thank you no no you
can run prompter
do you think that Sean Hannity has to do
this no he exactly what is written for
him by somebody else yeah yeah ha
screams okay so that's Christmas Valley
let's take a look at some of these
claims though that I think are pretty
important one of the claims okay and you
see this in the article not all from
that clip that the founding fathers they
encode a dehumanization and oppression
into the Constitution to preserve their
privileges are all direct quotes from
essence I highly recommend that you go
read them here's the truth that's
bullcrap
okay the entire world employed slavery
by the way not just African Americans
okay but sorry about that
sorry about that Amtrak thanks you the
point is all of human civilization
practiced slavery since the beginning of
time to one degree earned a lot of the
world still does we ended it and so this
is something that just shouted out a lot
and so people accept it as true the
founding fathers were they were actually
very troubled deeply troubled by the
idea of slavery and they were already
taking steps to try and pave the way to
change the course of history and end
slavery long before most of the people
were thinking about it okay so the
continuation of slavery was actually one
of the primary gripes against King
George before we declared independence I
have a quote here from Thomas Jefferson
King George the third the thirsty be
confused has waged cruel war against
human nature itself violating its most
sacred rites of life and liberty in the
person's of a distant people who never
offended him captivating and carrying
them into slavery in another hemisphere
or to incur a miserable death in their
transportation siddur
that's always a good word determined to
keep open a market where men should be
bought and sold he has prostituted his
negative for suppressing every
legislative attempt to prohibit or to
restrain this extra crippled commerce
that is he has opposed efforts to
prohibit the slave trade pretty clear
now again keep in mind this is something
that was not only legal but it was
enforced at this point right now let's
say that there's an unjust law you
disagree with often you'll hear people
say this to the right they go well if
you disagree with this taxation why
aren't you actually viola or why aren't
pro-life people being more violet with
abortion clinics because that's not what
we advocate we believe in working within
the law we believe in respecting the
rule of law even as we try to change it
through the system of law that we have
so let's keep that in context Benjamin
Franklin he said a disposition to
abolish slavery prevails in North
because that many of Pennsylvanians have
set their slaves at liberty and that
even the Virginia assembly have
petitioned the king for permission to
make a law for preventing the
importation of more into that colony
this request however will probably not
be granted as their former laws of that
kind of always been repealed now let's
go to some of the personal actions again
read the essence magazine is predicated
on the idea that our founding fathers
were pro-slavery and wanted to continue
it George Washington he made it so his
phrase could be sleeve his phrase phrase
I had a strong yeah his slaves could be
freed I'm talking like her it's a
continuum
he wanted his slaves to be freed upon
his death it was it was illegal by the
way to do so while he was alive
Jefferson by the way he maintained a
strong anti-slavery stance throughout
his entire life by his death state laws
had stiffened so much it was pretty much
impossible for him to free the slaves as
Washington had but Washington did that
upon his death he freed his slaves
here's another claim you see from
essence magazine and blacks it isn't it
crazy isn't it crazy think about this
for a second if I were to actually say
with a straight face blacks need to
leave that would be terrible be like her
writing for essence essence magazine
we're a far cry futility my memory is
she's going blacks need to leave she's
she lose here yes she doesn't I think
she splits her time between here and
Ghana cottage in Ghana avoid the
Warlord's are males there it is
remarkable do they always talk about
this too with Canada like a black should
move to Canada like okay well you pretty
much have it's pretty much the United
States only with worse health care when
they talk about slavery we escape to
Canada they would just say hey more
slaves okay get in line right here hope
you enjoy your shackles as though the
United States at the only place where
slavery existed another claim she makes
there is no corner in the United States
where it's safe to be black here's the
truth bows not even close no place in
the United States were it safe to be
black Plano Texas Burlington Vermont
Cedar Rapids
take your pick miss guess who as a
matter of fact do you know what do you
know were black you're black Americans
are safer in general in the United
States can you guys take a guess as to
where black Americans are safer in this
country nowhere tell us what is it
they're safer in white areas
predominantly white areas in black areas
as they're far less likely to be the
victim of crimes at the hands of white
Americans then fellow black Americans I
take no joy in that that's a statistical
reality but I won't I bet you won't
you're not gonna hear that on the SPLC
the latest hate crime email newsletters
and stuff they'll be talking about proud
boys getting into a bar fight with some
guys and bandanas around their face I
find interesting that there's no there's
no bit of irony to think about how we're
gonna change the system right and say
okay you know didn't have a black
president apparently have never had any
black Americans in any level of
government kill with impunity I think
that's the one that should be considered
the most offensive from a truth
standpoint right it is the idea that if
America has always been based on the
idea of oppression and dehumanization is
what you're saying you want to go to
Venezuela or how about right the Congo
well even worse than that when you say
kill with impunity that implies that
white people and by the way this is a
whole is there any worse generalization
you can make about an entire race of
people and let's include white people
here outside of they want to kill
anything that looks different from them
right yeah the insinuation that all
white people are just aching to when no
one's looking kill black people group
graphically gruesomely for no reason I
mean you really that is to assume that
we have no humanity that we have no
empathy for our filament it's just not
the case and by the way to tie that to
race is also inaccurate because many
slaves were sold from African slave
traders as a matter of fact eighty to
ninety five percent according to leftist
sources it's not even close the irony of
someone saying I'm going to look at you
based on your race and decide that you
have so little love and compassion in
your heart based solely on the color of
your skin that you will create an
oppressive nation and make no corner of
that entire country safe is literally
the personification of racism that yes
she is allegedly trying to combat
how about was a budget to get the
breakfast at tiffany's Mickey Rooney
look-alike here in this do do as to
black Americans being safer in white
areas all the afro mention cities Kate
they're all safer for black Americans
and predominantly black cities you can
look at the list
safest cities in the country by the way
for both white and black Americans you
can look at those stats then if you
wanted to find the least safe cities for
black Americans you would have to take
that list scroll down keep scrolling
keep scrolling police safe yep that
would be Detroit in st. Louis yeah I
don't know which I think Detroit is
worse but you guys have it pretty bad
yeah st. Louis's it's it's this is the
part where you argue for the check and
you say no no st. Louis is worse but
yeah st. Louis's definitely down we all
know it's the truth well but but I will
say like for example historically there
are parts of northern st. Louis or East
st. Louis which is actually in Illinois
yes I got stranded outside there my Ford
Taurus blew the transmission yeah not
good oh it was terrible yeah horses are
better yeah I you know the thing about
Detroit I've never been to Detroit but
I've done a lot of research into and
looked into it and frankly hear a lot of
stories from your dad about it yes papa
trout are always talks about it but when
you when you think about it I think some
people will hear what we're talking
about and draw a conclusion that oh it's
a it's a race issue as to why
african-americans are safer in
statistically in a white community but
it has actually nothing to do with race
it has to do with cultures that either
kids are concerned about lives or not
concerned about lives right that value
human lives or don't value human lives
and when you go to any city in America
whether it's Compton whether it's some
borough in New York whether it's Detroit
or whether it's st. Louis and Detroit
it's definitely worse just say I don't
value human life yeah and a good point
is that's not a race thing but I'll tell
you what is where you could attribute
something here to race you could
attribute the voting block and not black
Americans because you look at the
changes in the voting bloc under Donald
Trump but the activists like this writer
for Essence magazine and like the
activists who've tried to speak for the
black community to install is's that
have systematically destroyed them the
problem is a lot of these people are not
really representative of black Americans
go ask black Americans right now if you
could pay for a free ticket for them to
go to any country outside the United
States to live forevermore no one would
take it so someone like this let's be
really not a cleaner she doesn't speak
for most black Americans nor do the
BuzzFeed boldly lesbians we need to be
really clear about this I feel like
black people in the media unfortunately
are often represented by social justice
where your leftist
and not the true average black American
voice who is probably the moderate base
of the Democratic Party today right more
to the center more to the center than
anyone would consider them either based
on values or religion a deeply religious
history I mean so much of what I've
learned personally about Black History
Month is the connection to religion that
sustained families who were coming out
of slavery that's right yes today the
main message you hear is nope definitely
religion is for white people schooling
is for white people these are all the
young ones Yeah right like Millennials
and there's their right what I would say
is not it's not all of them it's the
what you're seeing in the vocal minority
Brian people like right here since of
alia are saying look at how bad this is
look let's all stand up and go and I say
make it like the club one in one out you
want to go
all right great we're gonna let someone
else come into the country who is
excited to be here and they know that
their skin color doesn't matter to their
ability to be successful right but it
matters to Christians ivali because how
many guess who characters are gonna fold
down when you get to the point you're
just winning you're stacking the deck so
yes listen even though you let's be
clear you may run into the occasional
let's say white racist farmer in Cedar
Rapids I don't know I'm not familiar
with Cedar Rapids if there's one farmer
listen don't look man I don't know close
call it your neighbor but a black
American is far safer say in Burlington
Vermont or Frisco Texas or Cedar Rapids
than Chicago it's not even close and the
good news is black Americans you can
move any of those places and you can
still get B et yeah
what about the o Network I I'm not
entirely familiar with the o network but
I've never watched it that being said
I'm sure there's a package available for
that Cu all the white people they get to
watch their Matlock and you black
American citizens you can watch your
your family matters or your mo ' need
big tech has something for everyone by
the way it's an Bell if you're
subscribed because subscriptions don't
mean a whole lot these days hit all
notifications and we also the channel
Crowder bits up on YouTube which is
ironically I think monetizing this
channel not don't even try to bug Club
we're funded by mugs not a foreign
caliphate here's another claim the term
black sit is used and she
uses this in her article in essence and
talks about it the term black soot is
used to describe black Americans leaving
the country due to racism to live
somewhere else and this is important
because this person is brought on to
television programs you can talk about
the blacks it you know and of course
usually everything used to be a gate
yeah after Watergate now everything's
like afternoon brexit was like brexit
black city exit bop it like that was a
fun flicking the bump it bump it bump
it's a hair thing is that a hair thing
goes under your hair makes you have a
bump oh yeah why would you want a bump
wondering I don't know you're gonna have
to ask someone says hematoma l'entrée
ladies can I look like I just went four
rounds with Buster Douglas and someone
has to put cold stainless steel calm for
us here I feel like that'll really work
for me it's a good look it's gonna catch
on no not bump it we were talking about
Popat blacks it let's go back to gate
black gate no that's
was that the prison in that where's Mary
yeah okay
so this term is used and what is that
assume it assumes that it's actually
going on a blacks it which is coined by
actavis it's not statistically there is
no black said funny story actually funny
you should ask viewer who I can't speak
with but I can spy on your webcam
because you never stick you know to use
expressvpn under President Donald Trump
the single fastest growing group of
legal immigrants is with a number of
African immigrants growing at a rate of
almost 50 percent one 2010 to 2018 and
in the Rose we're just Obama's half
brothers so much a lot of families don't
even know all that much that screams of
his father paternity test from his
father so by the way in this country
immediately following this is important
of the abolition of slavery some free
slaves were offered travel back to
Africa where there's a designated plot
of land for the people who wanted to
leave partially funded by Congress most
freed slaves were we were not thrilled
with it yeah they decided you know what
you keep your one-way you know what I
have heard of blacks it though really
actually I'm like no joke the actually
the article I read today about blacks it
was about the number of African
Americans who are deciding that they
cannot be a part of the Democratic Party
it is going to support socialism yeah
and and just saying this doesn't stand
by our values our values are more
aligned on the conservative side or at
least in the independent the 95 year old
Jewish crumb uh gene who tips 12 percent
doesn't do anything for them nothin he
doesn't have his finger to the pulse of
black America he doesn't someone tell
amazingly he needs to watch precious oh
it's true yeah that's it he's just a
little bit out of touch we all have our
blind spots okay
another claim yeah it is true is that
the kind of someone's black sit thing
and now they're trying to what's it
blinks it's Oh blech sick so this is
black sit as it like says just change
the letter no oh now not saying black
not blacks it not that blacks were
leaving are lazy you seven are lazy you
just changed one letter to get on CNN in
a quadrant view
with a new name all right here's another
claim this is from the article according
the SPLC you hear this a lot the number
of hate groups has risen truth very much
so the SPLC includes churches some of
which are thicker absolutely at least
half black churches and groups like the
proud voice which is a glorified
drinking club there aren't more actual
hate groups they've just broadened their
definitions second a review using the
same methodology okay so we're talking
about here is these widely touted hate
crime studies right here's a surprise
here comes from cold-water it showed
that clinton's rallies were linked to an
even greater rise in hate crime so even
a methodology is flawed or hilary is
100% neo-nazi only she just saw her she
has I just stopped a look at her stomach
at the valium pen calm her asked Hillary
Clinton is Edie furlong in American
history yet I don't believe that's the
case
I don't think that Hillary Clinton
having a rally where nobody shows up or
Elizabeth Warren is equivalent to
someone being curb-stomped in a hate
crime but if we're using your standards
you're worse yeah okay here's the
article right it goes on the site that
black Americans living in places like
Ghana and Qatar that they should be
places where black Americans maybe
should move to to achieve higher
standard of living and less
discrimination and they argue that some
black people have moved to these country
black people black people from you guys
this is the problem with this this is
this is a divide and conquer I'm sorry
even in my own head Rick I'm not gonna
lie to you I was a black blacks
african-americans I think right now I'm
just gonna say blacks because you know
my heart and I don't really care I can't
say African American we're talking about
a black American who went to Qatar few
black people white people that's an
easier descriptor for this right now you
want to say that that's racist okay just
like when I watched the UFC or boxing
and they described one guy in the red
trunks and one guy in the black trunks
well how he described the guy in the
black trunks as black him as white it's
a white guy in a black guy fighting why
do we have that's like we're going by
the trunks we're all going by the
melanin doesn't mean we hate the white
guy Tyson Fury I did him so the truth
and I don't not like the aunt a wilder
because he's black well there period the
truth about all its complete bull crap
the quality of life is far far lower and
places like Qatar despite what clock boy
tells you and they still have indentured
servitude to this day what happened the
slavery argument I know the Qatari
everything called sponsorship laws okay
sponsors can I want to make sure I get
this right cancel workers residency
permits prevent them from changing
employers denied them permission to
leave the country and they can report
them to the police if they do so they
are similar laws in the UAE other
countries in the cold states are you
it's a very extensive I mean yes see I
mean this is decades long and the growth
of UAE in other Gulf states I mean the
is especially affects like sub sub
continental Asia's like India Pakistan
right you know some of the Southeast
Asian countries where people come over
being told the exact lies that Christian
Cavalia whatever-her-name-is is saying
oh it's gonna be great the standard of
living is gonna be excellent it's like
yeah if you are the person hiring the
indentured servants their slave trade
was much worse than the American slave
trade like the the death rate was under
10 percent like 10 percent lived oh
really
yeah I mean the survival rate was that's
a bad survival rate it's less than 90
the numbers no it's true understand this
because they've just been saturated with
the idea that the Americans created the
slavery know in these countries there
there is no Harriet Tubman because she's
not even allowed to drive a choo-choo
also there are no Juju's Oh what Ben's
never been there well I don't know
because he was sued by clock boy he was
super would that be if Ben was had to be
extra Nachum up in that's another hoax
that no one no one really review yeah
right if you don't remember it was all
over the news it was like how dare this
school kick them out turns out it was a
total hoax the kid put a Philips alarm
clock and an old Samsonite well now we
don't revisit it okay good for you it's
good that you guys meaning the leftists
good that you control the media because
you never have to I never have to pay
for your mistakes by the way women in
prison in Qatar while we're not just
talking about people different races
women sentenced for being raped
sentenced to prison getting raped I want
to make sure that this is not hyperbole
at all an actual quote a Court handed
down a suspended one year imprisonment
sentence for engaging in extramarital
sex and deported her it also sentence
the man accused of raping her with 100
lashes for having extramarital sex and
40 lashes for drinking alcohol so she
and this is what's important not just
that she was punished for being raped
they acknowledge that she was raped
because they punched they punished the
man for raping her but he was punished
less severely than the woman who was
raped and 40 percent of that same
punishment was just because he drank
alcohol right exactly yeah just like do
those like I don't know transitive
property raping is if you drink two
bottles of alcohol right now much worse
it's the equivalent of rape listen I
just want to figure out my risk reward
ratio here about two shots of
Jagermeister okay okay that seems like a
fair trade this is going to hurt so
something else blacks it didn't get too
dark I don't like it the segment is dark
I he's a little bit talking about this I
hate that I have to acknowledge someone
who's a leftist activist claiming to
speak for black Americans telling black
Americans they should leave this country
because people like us want to harm
black Americans without impunity it is
just mind-numbing to me and you know
what that does that breeds more H hatred
with young black Americans if they see
their people in charge saying at all
time they're going to believe that
people like us hate black Americans and
want to harm we don't want that we want
to see that for anybody the exact point
here is to create division right right
exactly entire point is you should be
scared of anyone who looks or you think
looks white right bill sick today he's a
little more pale alright you're gonna be
fine no big deal you and John Henry good
buddies but no that's that's the problem
is this her entire mission is to be able
to create division without that division
no one gets her on the news right
anytime anyone puts her on there they
are literally saying I want to make sure
that this message of division based on
false facts is spread right now it's a
good point and by the way also the
proponent speaking of Asian and I
appreciate that you look whiter today
because of your violent illness they set
examples of blacks living in Egypt
Vietnam
so let's go the average yearly income in
a place like Vietnam is $2,300 for Ghana
2,100 Egypt you up at a little bit
$2,800 that's annual income so let's get
this straight
this author and proponents of the black
soup movement and the people on the
media who hosts them and their little
you know three sectional views despite
them being in the same studio that story
when I was I was in I don't know I think
it was CNN it might have been Fox News
this was years ago and they put us in
different like quadrants you know but we
were in the same studio right yeah I'm
Jordan and I said all right and it was
Doug shown I said all right Doug high
five and I reached into his quadrant
torn apart by the brass do that were
important they need us they don't need
us if they don't know that you're not in
a quadrant from different locales they
thought you were an Iowa man the whole
house of cards comes crumbling down if
you your hand goes in their quadrant
Doug shown my God he's one of the best
he's not quite Lonny Davis twenties
right up there so one second let me get
this straight was it a slight a little
bit yeah let's get this straight this
author and these people they're advising
blacks to move to places not only where
slavery is effectively still practiced
but where the yearly income is less than
three thousand dollars a year right well
the median yearly income the United
States has increased more than four
thousand dollars under Trump it's
increased more than the total salary
total income of people in these
countries and I get it but if you go
over there where are you gonna buy your
sweet kicks where will she get those
hoop earrings and ya know I yes exactly
I don't know I assume I assume that
they're they can probably steal them
from an indentured servant yeah that's
exactly it
that's humanizing those are shower
curtain rings a lot of people don't know
she's resource
recycling oh man good for the
environment so I think you will see this
narrative by the way we do have to get
going
to the Ash Wednesday I think you'll see
this narrative increasing as we go into
the election especially by the way if
Bloomberg is still in the race because
the argument on race will I think it'll
become even more
if it's if it's Bloomberg have it's if
it's Pete but gig expect more
accusations the argument I'll Center on
homophobia just like remember everyone
who voted against Obama was branded a
racist and then that switched to sexist
overnight when Hillary Clinton was
running if if the gay Alfred E Newman
look-alike secures a nomination then
they're gonna play the gay card for Pete
buggy but I think those are more sexism
and homophobia they're more like
seasonal they're more seasonal right
like pumpkin spice dish the race card is
always the ace up their sleeve even the
race card is like the star on the menu
that this is chef's recommendation all
the time I use mine all the time like
anytime someone's like Oh bill should
drive them like Asian no right not bunts
exactly and then for some reason then
sometimes you claim that you're a cholo
I'm definitely a chola yeah in my heart
if you just didn't correct them why why
not it kept me safe
I mean why why would i I've watched and
respond with yes a just writing an essay
so here's my pre-emptive question let me
ask you this genuine question where on
earth right now today in 2020 do blacks
have it better than in the United States
let me be quick is there some
discrimination of course to what degree
that's a conversation and one that I
think that we should have that's where
it's a productive conversation are their
individual racists absolutely
quarterback Garrett is proof slavery was
awful of course right god I have to be
really clear II have to say this 20
times the white person if you're even
touching sorry what's your opinion on
slavery was terrible was awful don't
make me have to repeat myself so if
someone cut to that of context you're my
lawyer you're gonna have to be my
defense team you don't want those kinds
of hours slavery
got it after we abolish slavery in the
United States it was still awful in the
continent of Africa and it's still awful
to this day in most of in parts of
Africa it's worse but in all of Africa
it's still worse than the United States
but see all of these things all the
above can be true
black Americans can face different forms
of discrimination and still be living in
the best place in the world for someone
of their skin color
period
maybe that's my blind spot talking white
privilege let's go to action Wednesday
[Music]
hmm that right there is the one
expensive item I own I was late for my
wife it's a very my wife got it she got
a great deal on it for our anniversary
and she doesn't owe me something special
and she always gets mad when I say my
wife got a great deal on it for
anniversary just like I got her oh nice
of you to join us there
Gerald Errol this time around his pants
would not suffice makes it for the Ash
Wednesday I love how we're covering for
the fact that we just didn't tell him
the by the way I also grew a beard my
wife hates me telling this story that I
got her wedding I got her engagement
ring on Craigslist that's a great deal I
got a great deal and I think you did I
know it's a by the way fresh ones that
you guys can send in your videos we take
your video questions that a lot of
credit I come / ass it's rice / asking
and sending your videos so what happened
was I was I decided I wanted to propose
to my now wife then girlfriend right
follow and I went on at this point I
don't really know anything so I said let
me look on Chris let's go check out to
what it brings on Craigslist so that
sounds good yeah so when I checked it
out and there was a woman who said this
is confirmed has the sales like code
they put them underneath a little time
in looking at you know this thing is in
a microscope but what is this thing
aluminum that's it sound scientific at
all a microscope a telescope what are
you guys a loupe know what like off 121
she what are you sending Muppets to
Fantasy Island so I can't help you this
is your language what am i right
and in China will be like 19 syllables
yes by the way I have a question for you
about wind Chung tonight so what
happened is it says okay this is a
legitimate ring and it's a steep
discount because I don't know this black
diamonds are they're valueless
effectively it's just the way that it
works the way the industry works so
diamonds from last year are like nothing
this year which is weird to me because
it doesn't seem seasonals it sound like
bell-bottoms they say diamonds are
forever not like diamonds are for the
spring
yeah the season for swimsuit season
nobody would see that James Bond movie
no and though you know what do we know I
didn't think that Octopussy would ever
be allowed on a poster yeah that's out
there great about that but don't worry
it's like what's this it's squid vagina
that is what Stephen Brendan Oh an
octopus is not a squid right finally
it's been years all squares and
rectangles so let me get to the story
that my wife hates because we're in awe
we had a slight disagreement this
morning and I really did want to dig the
knife in right now she hates me telling
the story that I had a great deal on her
English Hilary so I I meet this lady and
I noticed what's happening is she's
faking like she's on the phone because
she's posting ads and Craigslist for
these diamonds so she's under the
impression that I might rape her yeah
sweetheart I'll be home soon and instead
I'm like no no I'm not gonna no I'm not
gonna rape you I just want the diamond
and then diamond is a slang term or
ladies know the rock and then that's a
slang term for drugs right this part
it's not that sit true but she that's
that this wasn't what was most important
in to Zales and I said hey do you guys
use your loop and could you confirm they
said yeah we will confirm yeah that's
from last year's uh diamond and they
were trying to sell me on this year's
Diamond Collection alive I said no thank
you
so it was confirmed I purchased it at
like 50% off the purchase price nice and
my wife thought it was a sweetest thing
that she had ever received until I told
her the story and she was very pissed
she just didn't like that I'm more
enthusiastic about the discount than the
engaged now we've got into the meet yeah
you saved that money to spend on her in
other ways yeah yeah or an old Ford
Taurus I'm gonna tell you that every
time I didn't have any money also
doesn't work well I saved the money for
you honey we can she's like no fine cash
right now off the 405 like Eddie Murphy
wait hold on you're saying your wife
doesn't demand cash from you I told I
told mine that you come from the wet
markets are the least of your cultures
they sell wife's too yeah and you know
what they respect the man of the
household I will say that should I
didn't know a guy who actually did get a
Filipino mail-order bride and he was
like 90-something and I tell you what
they loved each other
until the day he died which it was very
it was a brief window three weeks later
yeah but she was really sweet so then
she been to America she did she had to
but she stayed with him uh what is
weighing everybody Wang Chung tonight
mean by the way I wanted to ask you that
not only half asian the only words I
know in Chinese are hurry up you're in
trouble you're fat
get over here because those things are
yelled at me but your mom yeah my mom my
grandma my aunts but I mean that's
everybody okay yeah
I felt loved what about how taste piano
key no no no let's go in the ears
white people terrible children
discipline your cruelty and your video
questions today around Wednesday and
also appearing we have a pairing Elmo
and some Buffalo Trace
didn't even send a picture of no picture
I don't believe them I think they're a
teetotaler who lies and they want us to
believe that their man but they're not a
Mormon
let's go to the first video from the
fans and start off Ash Wednesday hey
guys over at a lot of with Crowder how
you guys doing I've been watching you
guys a little bit it's been fun
hope you guys like the Bruins have over
here in New Hampshire I just want to say
I appreciate you guys doing that segment
with rhettandlink I'm like my thing I
had said
kind of walking through life with a that
kid who was struggling with his faith
and brought up a lot of the same things
that they're bringing up and I've
listened to their thing too because
that's a big thing with a high schooler
I lead a high school ministry right now
in my town and that's a lot of things
that are coming up right now with like
faith deconstruction and stuff like that
so I really appreciate you guys down in
that tonight love listen to you guys man
I'm praying for you guys it's been
pretty tough right now so hope you guys
are staying safe
guests have any advice and you know what
maybe are some good books to kind of go
to during this time especially for high
schoolers I appreciate that but stay
safe be good see you soon
well I really appreciate the I don't
think I got a name but I really
appreciate the video as far as which
books to go to how to edit yeah well and
I think he made a thread at the end see
you soon yeah I hope you like the Boston
Bruins hat huh why yeah first up why
would we like it and why would you hope
yeah
isn't there other like you could hope
for other thing lot of other things yeah
know that you don't get the okay you
know the hope for two things at the same
time hope hope you like the Boston
Bruins that I like because I'm from New
Hampshire first off oh okay I'm not
honor what the connects what I do
appreciate as far as books guy I assume
that he means like books on apologetics
that's really more Gerald in audio
Wade's territory yeah and I actually you
know you you taught me a lot about that
when we had to do the whole sort of a
talk Islam rebuttal oh yeah I'm which by
the way I appreciate you going in to bat
for me and it's the Pakistani government
know people who don't know if they go on
Twitter I had a formal complaint and
request of removal to Twitter from not
someone in Pakistan but Pakistan
[Laughter]
what's the kill stealing I didn't even
need to open the tweet in question that
was net worth of violation there I'm
pretty sure it's the painting there you
go yeah I do so uh you know in line with
a lot of this you know this quote
unquote deconstruction thing it
frustrates me I understand the language
but I do too and so that I guess where
I'm going people right now are bringing
up a lot of art is a better way of
saying it interesting did not so it's
two words I think it's - loose with the
hyphenation yeah we are yeah so I think
one of the one of the best books that
I've come across that really helps you
understand the Christian faith from a
non-christian perspective is and this is
out there and everybody talks about it
CS Lewis Christian wrote a book yeah
mere christianity it's fantastic so it's
a it's a great place to start for a lot
of people who don't want to read a
Christianese type of book yeah it's
something that's just you know big on
the language I was gonna say that but I
figured you had you guys had something
like that I figured that would be twelve
the vanilla even saying he thought you
had would have a better answer I do yeah
this is the beginning what would you say
their audio way yeah I'd also recommend
another CS Lewis book called miracles
I've really really enjoyed that one
that's more of a philosophical bent kind
of thing
not to be confused with that John
Travolta film yeah wait what am i here
at gold rustling a phenomenon and then
Michael similar covers powder
it's someone in a field yeah oh we're
supposed to be impressed
we're not nor was the sweetest Swedish
masseuse yeah another really great book
it's actually a debate book between
Christopher Hitchens and a guy named
Doug Wilson and they wrote articles back
and forth it's called is Christianity
good for the world oh yeah very short
little book but it really really
highlights a lot of really important
points yeah one would be God in the dock
that's my so I gave you the basic answer
fresh and this is a little bit more and
it's same kind of a second to Oprah's
Book Club yeah no no it's it's articles
back and forth essentially for a debate
club like you would bring up a question
and then later that I think it was the
next week the other person would have a
chance to rebut right she gave you time
to actually go it's not like a
johnny-on-the-spot thing like you have
to know the answer right now to write
this it's what's actual truth out there
what can we go find and yeah and I think
those books are really good and I would
say I'm often watching debates on yeah
and watch them on YouTube that's one
thing that you can really have access to
for a long time we felt like college
professors yeah either lecturing or
debating and you can launch that and
something that I've done quite a bit as
far as if you're talking about obviously
a knowledge base a biblical knowledge
base in theology you need to read a book
but if you're talking about sort of I
guess putting that in an environment or
making it appropriate you know having
appropriate information at the ready for
a debate that's where watching debates
live and what I'll often do is watch
debates live try and find the person who
I think is probably the best on the
opposing side of a posting point of view
and I'll pause it so what I'll do is
I'll have them answer like it's
real-time pause it and then answer as
though it's in real time right my wife
knows that I'll do that before whether
we do a change mind I have a debate here
on an actual debate on the show where
I'll just be in my office for because
listen I'm not a very skilled debater at
all I kind of fell ass-backwards into
this I'm not someone like a ben shapiro
or thomas soul but that is a really
useful tool and you say I am NOT going
to allow myself to stammer I'm not going
to allow myself to buy any type you just
act as though you are in front of that
lecture hall yeah how does it answer in
real time and it kind of get that
muscles like yeah I'd say one other
thing is a lot of folks refer to that
with yeah
that's what I was about why are you
stepping on my joke now the Chinese
audience knows the punchline but for the
Americans whatever
wait likes the racism a little bit I
know oh my we bond over it you say I
used to hate audio it's like I hate
audio I hate wades is to actually go
back because there's a lot of folks who
will say oh you know I read mere
christianity and maybe they read it and
you know he's leading a high-school
ministry which is excellent right but
some folks may have read this or read
parts of it or read it in the time where
they weren't ready for the message and I
do find that going back to reading some
of these books if you've read any of the
ones that were suggested you should go
back and try it again and read it again
because I think you will have a
different perspective yeah so that's
even at the very least even if you're
someone's like I don't know read a new
book just go back and revisit the old
one so yeah good opportunity i am i saw
i saw that joel has something to say but
i will say hey by the way my cigar today
is the Rocky Patel sun-grown Maduro was
rated I think number two and cigar
aficionados a cigar it was a 2017-2018
but the point is you know it's not my
favorite cigar that remains a mystery
I've never gotten more on social media
for people saying can you please tell me
about the cigar I've never said one
thing I want to keep for me I just list
I might as well just give away my
favorite things for free but it's a
limited run of cigars and I know that's
what we're a victim of our own success
we advertise things they sell out Rocky
Patel son John Maduro it's good but
there's not that good dog all right so
this is a broader point there when
you're leading a ministry like this like
these are not new arguments that are
that people are coming up with the
rhettandlink those guys they're not
coming up with new things that they're
are talking about like you can get
caught flat-footed sometimes in like
have you ever heard about the Egyptian
like Horus or something like this like
it just all existed before right yeah
you need to go out and watch somebody
who is and I know I sounded a little
like Alex Jones there on accident so I
won't be here tomorrow right people or
wrong people
see this broadcast they're trying to
control you through the tale Horus folks
the mind-control chemical agents do not
function if you purchase cool little
silver also 15 scrubbers exactly so I
think go out and watch somebody who is
making the arguments there's plenty of
people out there the atheists that are
making these arguments about you know
that the Bible isn't accurate it can't
be trusted and all these different
things don't just read up on
Christianity Today's website or
something like that somebody who's out
there saying oh no it's totally fine go
read what people are saying to these
people so that you can understand the
arguments that you're going to face
right it's kind of like when you prep
for I change my mind you you go through
all of the best arguments that somebody
could make and you're like what do I
think about these things it's a little
bit and I will say the changement line
approach and you know I know we should
write the book and get this out and
people have an important I I want to get
it out to you right now just you know if
you join up at mug Club it allows us to
do all of these things right give them
away it effectively up the price of cost
but um change my mind is a good approach
because it's a Socratic method where
people often say all the debate well no
we've actually debated plenty people on
the show yeah and we have calls out to
professors as a matter of fact the last
change with my mind we did we were
called up by a professor we said well
let's do a debate and then you know they
don't want to do it but cheer on is not
a debate it really is ironically about
trying to change somebody else's mind
and allowing them to approach you and
change your mind so in a
non-confrontational manner especially
with issues of faith I think that's a
good way to handle it yeah look at
conversations there are two things I
have you know in kind of doing research
like when we do a meat segment you know
a brilliant researcher reg who's just so
much smarter than I could ever hope to
be and I'm thank Christ he's on our side
thank you for Reggie thank you he
doesn't hate me yeah because he could
destroy everything that I hold dear so
now I actually say that prayer literally
it's the Crowder prayer and we kind of
do when we do research for the meat
segment we go okay what's the fastest
route to victory or what is the need to
know that's very very different from
trying to convince someone as to why
your point of view might be valid that's
a long long ball approach it takes kind
of guiding them down the path and
setting them to question their points of
view at first and I think was especially
with faith because at a certain point as
bold as some Christians out there want
to be there's always an element of faith
not everything can be answered and so
you
to be prepared for that and you have to
create some kind of a connection before
you go into some kind of information
that you think is a trump card and
anyone who tells you it's easy or it's
simple has never done it in real life
because it is not easier simple and you
can be caught flat-footed especially if
you like that's what happens with Trump
and debates they there prepare you know
Ted Cruz I guarantee you was prepared
for all curve balls yes your dad killed
JFK face scoreboard ask hey Stephen this
is a fan here I want to ask you a quick
question
currently on my toilet as I should be so
I just I asked this girl prom and she
said yes thankfully I don't want to do
next
I don't know her she talked to her via
text I don't know I don't want to pursue
a relationship with her at all yeah
that's kind of all what I have to say so
thank you I do see you later
touch her to see what she does do not do
that do not follow well even in crowded
I'm out of answers
so now unless he was referring to the
eastern tip a very nice little yellow
bird yeah yes but no otherwise why were
you on this I have so many questions
about the questions a lot of their
assumptions like I'm in the bathroom as
I should be along with my Boston Bruins
camp I would a completely G her happen
your Bruins kept how funny would it be
if he was just wearing a New Jersey
Devils cap in his toilet was one big
Boston Bruins that would be great that
would be a way so so he asked a young
lady to prom that she said yeah not want
to pursue anything with which it's fine
whatever if you're gonna treat that we
could show you though but why would you
if you're gonna do that why would you
continue to what's what's the question
man take your brow from it's a beard
it's got to be beer
that was where I was gonna go I was as I
had a girlfriend in high school who was
she was a sweet girl she did nothing
wrong she was very pretty out of my
league and what happened was I just
wasn't over my other girlfriend I dated
a girl for like five years and we broke
up for a period of about a year and so I
asked her out and then I realized that I
still had a thing with I still had
feelings for my ex girlfriend and I just
avoided her I don't know for like a
month and a half and I still feel bad
about it because she did nothing wrong
and I wanted to I didn't want to be
unfair to her and build up a really
intimate relationship and then cut it
off and so I just try to just broken up
with her so maybe he's coming at it from
that angle where sure he didn't really
want to go to prom with her but maybe he
felt that she was lonely and he's
gracing her with that punim yeah she
should be so grateful right well here's
the thing you know that silver lining
proms aren't happening this year so I
guess your honor that's off on her door
handle call it a day who sent in a
question about asking someone to a prom
that's not happening mm-hmm I think he's
a liar that was a toilet I think that
was a glorified bird day the bird day
every day is in a toilet all right
someone else talk so what do we have any
other questions yeah we have plenty of
other questions I guess we ran out of
runway on that one pretty quickly it
does a runway that was an Eastern
African completely deserted bombshell
runway of a question but they've gotta
be African could be in the yunnan
province haven't you seen Lord of war
come on but if that's the question maybe
it's like whose favorite film is
Constantine just referenced this
Nicholas that is this movie yes not yeah
he's done he's done sorry you had one my
guy that's middle of the road for him
okay really pretty you're in your best
pics it's upper echelon
yeah that's top five
it's not warlord this guy I'll just try
to assume that he's asking a reasonable
question which is I asked a girl to go
to prom don't you love how way audio
weight is like the friendlies most
polite guy when he delivers the biggest
gut punch assumes everyone yeah thank
you guys yeah so I'm assuming that he
means I asked a girl to prom
proms canceled I guess he left that out
oh and then now what do I do because I
feel like I have initiated something
with her but I don't want to continue
anything I so he maybe you just raise
your he needs to learn how to
communicate better if that is the actual
question that for us a little bit better
that's the first step your communication
skills in a relationship we're gonna be
really important yeah did anyone get the
feeling that Gerald identifies with the
girl in this question never been kissed
and was like look at the poster I guess
and I don't mean mr. Arquette yes what
something will look David David David
right take your 77 cents and shut up
it's true do it lucky if we assume this
guy's asking a reasonable question yeah
and my thought is he and he doesn't want
to pursue anything he should just not
text her there's no problem was the
what's the touch your teeth didn't see
what happens that's what the card we
can't see each other they're not going
to prom how is he going to do that
logistics Steven Gerald did you say teat
I did oh my god and I don't was the
practice
word Jerell I wanna hear you say what
was the original word breasts that's not
the word at all no teton I really
appreciate the disappointment like a
father who caught his 14 metal child
scrambling porn from the dish what the
cable Dish satellite he's scrambling no
kids don't understand this nowadays they
have inaudible and it's disgusting I
think you I think this is one of those
deals where really just be
straightforward just literally like hey
uh sorry proms off Thanks have a nice
life that's it you know and she says
then it's her pro am i cute say no and
then just go on your merry way that's a
good that's actually a good point yeah
hey hey even better to send her a link
to this video right now I feel bad about
everything we've done I don't she's
watching this hey hey if you're watching
this young lady you could do better have
any hockey finale all right let's go to
the next Craig yes man these are these
are not questions that really give us a
lot to mind or no talk to you ladies but
I really want my bill Richman's what are
some of your favorite classic
action movies and also I have something
pretty cool shoes check this out
[Music]
[Music]
okay before we go anything fun do you
see this see smoking is cool listen up
it was a faithful faithful race you'll
be cleaned engine bills is probably lord
of war but my favorite like as far as
bad action film because I think most
action films are terrible and she see
themselves in the thinking that they are
good yeah Cobra is what it is it is the
ultimate bearable film because there's a
little hint of self-awareness but not
enough to make the bad not a level worth
appreciation true yeah so half Asian but
you are a connoisseur so so contextual
II actually there were only growing up I
only watched one action movie and I
watched it over 30 times because it was
the only video that we had on tape at my
house that was an action movie and I was
grounded the rest of the time yeah I
couldn't watch TV whenever we didn't
have cable or you know obviously there
was no YouTube at that time or whatever
else you used to steal movies so I
watched speed over 30 times portion of
yourself in kyon oh I did right so
you're so high I really so it's
unfortunately like I have not seen a lot
of what people consider to be the
classic action movies like I didn't see
Top Gun until I was in college right
what so yeah and I at that point like I
was still like I get why people like it
but I don't personally like it right
so speed okay yeah speed you go bruh is
right up there for me as far as action
films I think as far as the best kind of
action film that's actually it would be
Terminator 2 its I don't know how James
Cameron right yet it's the only time
that I can think of and yes I am
including the Alien films comment below
I don't give a rat's ass your I was told
not to answer by this oh that's right
but nonetheless it
obviously we don't have any respect for
the people that s the question we got to
give you a hard time
like Carol - oh no I love terminator -
that's the very very very best like as
the bad ones that are kind of funny like
tango and cash was like badly funny you
know what I mean and then I actually
like predator a lot yeah recent predator
was the best in the series tomorrow with
the peel is that yeah separate black I
know they are but they the names I don't
know which I really don't is it key mr.
Hall and Oates and I know they're not
black but Michael key keegan-michael key
Tegan I was actually very good I was
reading fighter because it didn't take
itself seriously it was kind of a wink
and a laugh at the branch oh yeah well
as far as classical stuff I really liked
the old image and a possible TV show I
really enjoyed that
you must have we need to replay that 19
minute question film films yes fine
[Laughter]
pre-written through line of crapping on
everybody he's not so quick on his feet
do you like I like I like old westerns
so like but those aren't really action
films I don't really yeah so it's like
an old John Wayne movie like you know
Rio Bravo John Wayne films I like The
Shootist
shoot it's not really an action film but
I feel it's it really sort of it's it's
sort of like the Heath Ledger scenario
with John Wayne films he was riddled
with cancer he was dying in real life
and he was dying in the film yeah and
just it just kind of captured everything
at that moment well I'm really well so I
do like that film wars I think though
that a lot of people remember John Wayne
films is better than they were some of
them are good but a lot of them were
crap yeah but some of them are great
ones I mean searchers and stuff like
that is that yes yeah I think it's
always among what usually you look at
top westerns I think it's usually
searchers or Unforgiven or
interchangeable sure and I do prefer
Unforgiven but searchers drink yeah
same writer I'm gonna do one uh predator
yeah
hard guy cards awesome those are my
three aliens awesome is a sequel to
second one PD that's the second one the
first one was more of like a thriller
horror movie the second one was in
action yeah I'll give you that you know
what bothers me about action films
people was getting mad about this is no
I think they really sometimes take men
for granted and just assume that men are
dumber than they are now we all like
some some action films obviously all of
us here have action films that we like
but for some reason they just they put
just like crappy rom-coms were they like
women will like this no matter what they
just assume that we can make Terminator
19 yeah and guys will just accept it
because there are guns that go off there
was a kid I was no longer friends with
him because of this conversation I won't
even use that name because I don't want
to give him I don't even want to give
him the benefit that I built this
platform mr. Goll that's his last name I
won't give him a friend was talking
about xxx and I was at the cinema guzo
which was where I was raised in green in
the South Shore of Greenfield Park the
next town over and totally by the way
also connections with the mob like
exactly we would think with cinema boots
oh yeah they were going to see xxx
and then I was seeing something anything
other than xxx yeah and I remember a kid
saying what my other friend Adam saying
well all is it this is what we're going
to see is it any good and the kid go the
kid goes the other boobs in it oh my god
and then he goes no no trust me look at
all these cool guns and like well no no
what's this what about the plant what
about the storyline and they just
assumed that all guys are like this 13
year old mr. Goll who just go there to
boobs in it or their guns and maybe that
works for people who don't like have I
have access to a lot of really cool guns
in real life I don't need to watch Vin
Diesel with horrible trigger discipline
and breath sunscreen in which he could
not be less interested it's just like I
wanna watch if action is a part of it
then great but I don't like it when they
just think wow let's just toss action in
it and guys old guys will pay the for
the for the ticket yeah if there's no
mix oh if there's no you're not mixing
the action in with the story itself it
does definitely was on it that at that
point it's what are they call a gun porn
or action porn yeah it's just literally
where you're literally just doing it for
the reaction of the action explosions
which takes away from it so yeah I like
some of the films that I really like and
some of my favorite films which I know
is kind of people as well you don't like
action films a great film that I think
is very very underrated and I don't know
if I put this in my list of did we ever
do a list of top five most underrated
films
maybe not let me know we have you can
comment let me know obviously the edge
know my favorite film I think it's
criminally underrated but there's a film
with Kurt Russell called breakdown did
you receive that film oh my gosh it's so
good white button-down shirt yeah his
wife their their car breaks down and
they stopped to make a phone call I mean
his wife is gone yeah so that's how ya
nineties Kurt Russell thriller and
that's a genre of film that doesn't
exist a whole lot anymore so it you know
that's sort of like Basic Instinct fatal
attraction and then breakdown is very
underrated in my opinion it's more of a
suspense thriller film but those gems
kind of they're not Marvel Universe and
they're not cheap indie crap that goes
on Netflix that you know maybe at 10:30
at night you go alright it's not it's
somewhere in between and that's that
sort of doesn't exist anymore yeah and
and that's really kind of my favorite
genre my wife and I like people often
talk about how my wife wants to watch a
rom-com and I know I actually like
romantic comedy some of my favorite
films are romantic comedies but both my
wife and our favorite films typically
are that genre of sort of suspense
thriller which usually includes action
but it's it's not - hey but you
choo-choo like listen I have so many
guns yeah it's not like I have an
obscene amount of God so what one movie
did I think you liked that might be
considered an action movie was like hell
or high water relatively recent consider
that an action movie that I really
enjoyed that was almost it wasn't
big-budget like that but it was yeah one
of the rare sort of exceptions you
haven't seen hell or high water and
talked about and this is one thing I
will say about hell or high water
Ben Foster everyone knows what a great
actor he is and honestly the the the
least impressive performance in there
was bridges because it's Connor he's
kind of doing the Pearl Jeff burgers now
sure yeah yeah yeah and Chris Pine for a
guy who sort of considered a pretty boy
and come on those I lost in them but
he's a very good actor
yeah and he's on screen with people who
would be typically seen as character
actors and people would sort of say well
he's the eye candy to sell he's sort of
the leading man he never gets upstaged
by people and I don't think he gets
enough credit for that I think there's a
really good actor who's excellent it
does seem like we have a lot of extremes
with films now right like you said the
Marvel Universe and then the other stuff
kind of at the bottom and I do miss
those really good like fun easy to watch
movies that kind of surprise you a
little bit it doesn't have to be like a
you know thriller that surprises me or
something like that but something that's
better than I think it will be yeah and
usually it's like the overhyped over
budgeted movie or or something that's
really crappy like is there and maybe
that's a good question like is there a
movie you guys have seen recently there
like in the theaters that you were like
recently saw Richard Jewell okay it was
good it was good and one thing I'll say
clinics would always brings the best
performances out of his actors but he's
very reliant on sort of his director of
photography because the light there's
some scenes rule that lighting like it
really looks amateurish or American
sniper where they have the rubber baby
yeah yeah I mean there are little things
like that because the Clint is just you
know it's like you didn't even say
action right when you feel like taking
it so he's really focused on
performances which is that great and he
always comes in under time under budget
but he needs to be surrounded and that's
why you can see some inconsistency and
sort of the technical acumen maybe in
some of his films needs and surrounded
with technical geniuses who also needs
someone like a Clint Eastwood but
Richard Jewell there are some periods in
that there's some points in that film
where uh Sam Rockwell and I forgot the
name of the guy we just saw an old key
and peele sketch the from I Tanya the
guy who's Richard Jewell there's a scene
at a diner where you just go all right
if they were to mail him the Academy
Award here it wouldn't be out of line
yeah it's very good if you haven't seen
it I do recommend Richard Jewell there's
everything you guys have seen reason we
have to get going anything recently you
recommend for people to see especially
on the Mudd Club quarantine may have
been made in two years ago so it's out
now and obviously in every place it was
two years ago it's now
sorry so I think it was a quiet place I
haven't gone back to rewatch it but in
the theatres that was very look how he
says like he's letting people like he's
given in the inside lane limited
theatrical release to only 9400 yeah was
good I was very surprised by it in the
movie like he was just great because it
brought me in in a way that I have it
was a good felt in a lot of have you
seen the the really crappy version it
was Stanley Tucci on Netflix it's called
something like I don't know what it's
called so money someone please let me
know forgot the title of it but here's
the thing it's basically the same thing
if you talk the monster see but they're
like little bats no oh my gosh think
about think about ripping ripping
something off turned out that was
actually adapted from the original novel
and a quiet place was the one that
ripped it off but it got the theaters
more quickly
well good but this one I mean you think
okay Stanley Tucci he's almost never in
something bad I'm like you know your
folk you're Nicolas Cage and this is so
bad it might have been called like the
place that is silent yeah one one movie
it's older that I really enjoy the
action and even though some of the other
parts of the movie are weak is
equilibrium with Christian Bale yeah
really really yeah I think the Thea the
themes themselves are really interesting
I don't think they execute on the story
as well some of it is a little
disjointed and a little bits a little
campy yeah but I thought the action and
that was really good and some of the
stuff was science fiction in a way where
you're like ooh I could I could see that
happening or some of those interesting
things kind of that was my go-to
blockbuster pick you know it's funny
like I've taught how terrible I am with
names yeah but I have just the way my
brain works to spit I never forget a
face and never forget a voice when I
think of equilibrium I think of and
maybe someone can bring this up er look
I think of that film was at Daybreakers
daywalkers with Ethan Hawke cuz the
cover few races event horizon yes yeah
or like Broken Arrow and face off John
Travolta that's another with the whole
meat segment on that
yeah that's a phenomenon phenomenon has
caught but that's what it so that's why
think about equilibrium but what was
equilibrium I don't know anything about
so it's in the future people take these
there's like a dictatorship that
overtook the government's kind of like
dictator so kind of a yeah so you take
you take medicine to make you happy and
then some people are like wait I don't
want to take medicine anymore and one of
the guys who's one of the elite guards
takes a different path
oh is this have already put in your eye
the medicine yes you squeeze it like I
know you it's like a second in some is
there a scene where someone comes home
and it's like basically long before
Alexa but like a whole Alexa apartment
telling you to reminding you to take
your medication hmm actually does happen
but I don't think it's an eye dropper
and I think I know what you're talking
about it it's a different oh I think I'm
thinking a black carbon that show but
how do I remember that somewhat if you
go and watch me but oh that's the exact
scene yeah and there's and just because
I watched it and I thought ooh that
there was something about upgrade ooh
upgrade is up drops no this is a guy who
and a thing that tells him to take his
medication and he stops taking it but
yeah his whole body is he's a great
excellent and he gives a [ __ ] makes his
body like superhuman and it takes over
his mind and stuff it's actually really
that's one with a guy who played the
brother in the OSI O'Connell's like Tom
Hardy but yes rent Tom Hart nor Lord of
war on the Lord I hope you need to
purchase some guns Ash Wednesday and of
course tomorrow we are going to be live
I don't number who the guest is but of
course we still have our marquee guests
on Thursday and good morning mug Club
Monday Wednesday Friday morning through
the whole month of April quarantine is a
promo code please renew if you are
already a mutt club member we need you
because YouTube don't pain us and thank
you so much we love you we'll see you
tomorrow
[Music]